the Resident Evil 2 remake is a
terrifying game fortunately for you I've
got some tips that'll hopefully help you
navigate through Raccoon Police
Department
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
refer to your map often if you didn't
notice your map is color coded blue
means you've searched it and red means
you haven't so if you see a room that's
red you could be missing some ammo some
herbs or something else that could come
in handy later down the line it's also
smart to plan your expeditions
especially later in the game when you're
being chased by this guy you probably
want to figure out where you need to go
and what's the quickest way to get there
you've probably noticed that as you
explore you might find gun parts which
you can combine with some of your guns
these can boost your accuracy and clip
size among other things but they can
also take up more space in your
inventory and Resident Evil 2 it's very
important to organize your inventory and
sometimes these guns can be a little too
big if a gun you like is too big because
of a part you added you can always
remove that by highlighting it and then
you can just remove the part beautiful
quick-turn has been a big part of the
Resident Evil series and it is here in
Resident Evil 2 if you haven't noticed
by now you cannot open a door with your
back to it you're gonna have to flip
around and the best way to do that is by
holding back on the control stick and
pressing circle or B that way you can
turn around nice and quick wooden boards
are your friend you can use this to
reinforce windows so zombies can't break
in if you do a lot of backtracking and
Resident Evil 2 this can save you a lot
of resources and a headache later down
the line you'll also want to know your
sub weapons you have the flashbang knife
and hand grenade you can use these items
to escape an enemy if they grab you
unless it's from behind and by using one
of these you won't take any damage you
should also know that a knife will break
after a while so keep an eye on its
durability and keep in mind if you use a
knife to escape an encounter you have to
kill that zombie before you can get it
back
[Music]
but if you aren't sure if it down zombie
is gonna get up again I recommend
knifing it we call this the knife check
and you can check to see if it's alive
if they move they're gonna get back up
and probably screw you over later if
they don't they're dead cool well dead
is I guess as dead as a zombie dead can
get you get to a point where the tyrant
or mr. X will follow you around the
building and ruin your day it's not
worth wasting any resources on him
because you can't kill him however if he
does have you trapped you can put a few
rounds in his skull and he'll neo that
way you can run away liquors can f you
up fortunately if you move slow you can
sneak your way around them however there
are some cases where you're gonna be
trapped in a narrow hallway and there's
not really a way around them I typically
like to bait them by the door and then
hit him with the big guns
[Music]
every now and then you might find an
item that you aren't sure what to do it
the first thing I recommend doing is
examining it a lot of times there's a
latch or something you can interact with
from there that will hopefully give you
something of use you've probably noticed
by now that there are a lot of safes and
locks scattered around Raccoon Police
Department make sure to read through the
notes you find because a lot of times
you can find a code or combo in those
documents most times they'll even tell
you where that locker safe is located so
it shouldn't be too hard to figure out
which code goes with what and if you
find a roll of film make sure to develop
it in the darkroom a few of the games
secret items can only be found that way
those are just some tips we have a game
spot but if there's anything I missed or
something that you think is really
important that other players should know
leave them in the comments below and as
always thank you guys so much for
watching
[Music]